so
i'm dan sylvester there is
gord and he'll join the talk shortly so
we're here to talk about it the original
title was uh
distributed parallel computing over
multi-machines and multi-cores
in javascript using node but i couldn't
fit it on the slider so anyway so i'm
assuming that you guys are here
um because you know computering is hard
and we're getting to this point where
we've lost the ability to
um you know just saying oh well my cpu
is just getting faster and faster and
faster so
it's becoming more of a parallel
processing world out there
um and so before we jumped it out who we
are
um and this isn't really a plug but gord
and i both from
bit hound we're sponsoring here come
chat with us afterwards
you can follow us on twitter confusement
and gore tanner
and you might know us better from our
cosmonaut survival kits that we've
doled out and i keep hearing the lasers
go off so thanks
um so what do we do and this isn't again
a plug for a company but this is why
we're here talking about distributed
computing we are here to help you write
better code but to do that we have to
analyze all of your repositories
and all of the code in them and that is
a lot of work that needs to be done
right so kind of a typical problem
you want to run lint um you have
something that's never run lint before
and this is an actual case i just i
won't name the project
7368 right that's how many linters door
and it took 29 seconds to run this now
if we want to run this over
i know a thousand commits and we have
multiple multiple
critics or analyzers that we run uh this
becomes quite onerous and you know some
of this processing if you were to do it
sequentially will take
two three four hours and um you know
waiting sucks and we hate it we're we're
on patient people
but we have a bit of a challenge in
javascript in that you know we're single
threaded
so how do you go about
processing many many many things um and
still
you know making things performant well
so there's the cluster api
node anyone who use cluster at all
okay that's pretty cool there's a little
bit of overhead but it's kind of nifty
because essentially
um it's you know
the procedural.exec and it just it
allows you to spawn processes
and can take advantage of all the cores
on that one machine
and that's nice but that means you just
have to buy bigger and bigger and bigger
servers that have more and more cores
and they
cost a lot of money and you know for
startups that gets expensive
um so to the cloud all right let's let's
go out there and
and use a whole bunch of different
machines
and max all of those out and see if we
can get
performance to increase and go better
and
so that's kind of what we do and this is
where zeromq comes in
has anyone used zero mq
oh awesome cool if you have that
installed on your laptops by the way you
could actually join a demo later
um so i you know i read the description
the first time i saw zrmq
it's like looks like an embeddable
networking library but acts like a
concurrency framework you know wow
that's a whole lot of buzz
words and i don't know what any of this
means so we started kind of looking into
it
deeper so this is totally legit this is
off of
their manual so you basically take tcp
sockets you add some spandex cosmic rays
illegal radio scope or yeah
radioisotopes from secret soviet atomic
city
and then that all of that stuff together
and you end up with
um zero and q sockets and really awesome
things
so essentially the stocks you know the
carry atomic messages
across multiple transports like that's
kind of the key here for us as well
so you can do it in process enter
process tcp multicast
and you can connect sockets
um well as many of them as you'd like
and there's multiple patterns that you
can then take advantage of right
there's the fan out fan in and we'll
talk about that that's part of
gourd's demo we can do pub sub
task distribution and then obviously the
standard kind of request response
and request reply and this is kind of
the
you know simple i've got some tasks to
be done i'm going to send it out there
whoever is out in the cloud that is
available to do the work will just pick
it up
do what they need to do and come back
the the pub sub i'm sure all of you are
familiar with it
within bit hound we use that mainly for
all of our stats so we've got
all of these distributed nodes you know
doing work or being idle or whatever
and we want to understand you know what
our performance is at the very so they
all just publish their stats and
we have kind of this aggregator that
sits there and listens and
um you know provides us with our with
our stats tooling
but this is really where all of our work
um comes in and this is the fan out and
then fan back in so
what we do is we have batches of work
that need to be done
let's say we have a thousand commits
about a dozen critics that we need to
run
we fan those out and you can do that in
batches or you can do it all at once
it's up to you
we do hours in batches really to kind of
maintain a more shallower q depth
so we can better utilize multiple
requests for repositories
each one of our slaves goes off and does
some work
and when it's done it kind of responds
back and we aggregate
all of those results and we end up with
with what's on our website
so i was kind of a quick run through
what xero mq is and and how we use it
and
how you can go about doing distributed
computing but that was just a theory
essentially so we can prep for gourds
part of the talk
so i've gone six minutes so you have an
extra four
giddyup nice of course i prepped for an
extra four minutes
um so when dan told me uh we were doing
this talk
and said you're doing the code portion
of distributed computing in javascript i
thought this is going to be fun
so he's like you just need to come up
with a really awesome demo
and my mind was racing i was like oh i
could do like i don't know like what
about fibonacci that's not controversial
in the node community
but that would be boring so i i racked
my mind for
a long time running different things and
it actually
the idea for my demo kind of came from a
ride with my
daughter taking her back from school
she's sitting in the back and we kind of
have a little conversation it's a good
time to catch up with your kids
and she just randomly asked me daddy how
many letters
are in 10 and being an
incredibly common question i said
three why and so she sits back there and
she goes well
well if ten has three letters
and three has five letters
and then we worked it out okay well five
has four letters
and four has four letters that works
and i was thinking this is odd
so we we worked we worked out a few more
numbers and she's like oh it's another
number i'm like i don't know like 13.
she's like oh that's a lot of letters
and we worked through it and back and
forth and they everything kept
reducing down to four and
this was such a amazing experience
like i i had to take a picture of it
because it was this serendipitous
exchange between me and my daughter
where i'm sitting there thinking i have
to have a compelling awesome
example for distributed processing and
here's my daughter sitting in the back
doing
word games and number games with me so
that
that is actually my face my mind was
blown that
that this happened so the key is
everything can be reduced to four
um i i'm not
i'm not one to preach a religion ought
to you but
just so you know there is a real
religion it's on urban dictionary so
it's legit
called foreign it's a religion based
solely on the worship
of the ever cool four often
involving telling tales and giving of
muffins
but we're a startup so you can buy your
own muffins
so i decided you know what
i'm going to create an npm module called
fourism
um i created it kind of last week
somehow 34 people downloaded today with
without me even telling you about it so
kudos
um i have no idea how people are
downloading that but
so it's the official launch of fourism
for this talk only and don't ever use it
so for those of you who know about xero
and queue if you do have the zero mq
libs
installed you can easily npm install
fourism
and you can participate in this demo um
it's also the codes on g
tanner foreign not that you really want
to look at that
but give you a quick idea of this so i'm
just going to make this bigger because
my eyes are old so
i need to create a couple a couple small
modules so
first i need to create a module to like
take a number and wordify it which is
a new word for me so
we'll start here and let's take 10
and that returns me low and behold 10
and because the word the number four is
the greatest four you will notice that
it also returns
four
but it works up to like really crazy big
numbers
10 trillion 43 billion 252 million
352 356.
so that was a fun module i didn't really
write that so i can't take much credit i
grabbed it off a blog post somewhere
that's the wrong module
oh that could have been bad um yeah
so andrew hoyer if you're here thank you
i didn't have to write that but it's a
really really fugly looking code that
that does that for me so we won't look
at that ever again
um so also we needed to do the the
little game my daughter played and
i little did i realize that she was a
prophet
in this new religion that we're going to
talk about
enlightening us all so we can take our
example 10
i will pass the word
10 to 4 ism and we'll log that and it
returns
four
now i know some of you are kind of like
what so i'm just like you're just kind
of like
huh so if i just kind of pass in huh
it'll uh
expand out and we'll see that little
exchange i had where 10 has three
letters
three has five five has four and four
has four
and of course i wanted to play around i
was like oh cool like
let's do that awesome like 13 example
it's also four weird
now i was playing around with this and i
noticed that there's there's some ones
that take a little
longer like one two three which
could be also four so if i run node
talk so this this example is really
interesting where
23 has 11 letters 11
has six six has three three has five
five has four and four has
four those seven steps
and seven is really close to four
it all relates because if i took if i
took seven
that took three steps and if i took
three
we all know that three i should save the
file
three took three steps oh whatever i
thought it'd be funny i didn't actually
prepare that
so that's cool it's not really a
distributed but it takes a little time
and i'm like okay i want to
i want to like for fly all the numbers
so starting off
i i made this little program it's really
not not a whole lot so i wertify i made
a utils just to like
log log the results so i'll keep track
of my counts
for one to a million i'm gonna foresm
wordify
the x keep track of the turns and this
node sample
and there was light thank you for
so that took about four seconds
so obviously this is going to take a
long time
oh my gosh i am probably going to hell
for this talk
it took a little time and i was like
it's going to take a while and this is
distributed computing
talk so let's kind of go let's do this
first thing and we all have played with
cluster before so i took the same code
you'll basically kind of see right here
the
wordify forism it pretty much the same
code except
i'm just grabbing the start and end from
the process
environment and then when i'm done i
send it back on process so
if if you're you're clusters you have a
master and he delegates to his slaves
so i have a little send function where i
just kind of i'll fork off a new process
i'm setting start and end and when i get
the message back i'll call my callback
and just to make this easy to do the
synchronization i'm using the async
library which
we all love at bit hound it's an awesome
library for doing
callback management so i just let's do 5
million
on my i opted for the cheap cpu on my
macbook air
so just wait for it
wait obviously
when someone hits our website running
this this religion
20 seconds a long time to wait for our
response
you see there's really not a whole lot i
can do to optimize this
like i could buy a bigger computer but
i'm
poor um but we're kind of limited to
like how many cores we have and we could
do distributed kind of
like we have like a proxy in front of
our like node server and it'll like go
to each one but i will have state i kind
of want to go i want to do
when you request like the supreme
knowledge of the number four you want to
know
all the numbers at the same time so
that's that's where
the true beauty of foreign lies
so basically there's a lot of code here
just want to make it pretty but
at the root of it
you'll you'll still see i still have
this little
thing here so counts
loop over here return accounts and it's
called back and then
back on the slides
where are we here so all i'm really
doing is
using the push pull sockets so
0mq sockets have basically called types
and the types are not really what you
would think a normal socket type a lot
of socket libros would be like oh you
want your in
process socket or your like tcp socket
your websocket one of the key
components of xeronkey is you kind of
assign like
message balancing type so you have a
push socket which is
you can push out messages and a pull
socket which will
pull messages from a push socket so this
this kind of diagram here is really all
i'm doing in this example where i have
a task ventilator where i'll push out
these like little batches of a million
processors and i have my workers well
i'll just call pull
and then push back to the ventilator
so that's what you're seeing here where
i pushed result back
pull it on and then
really all i'm doing is um calling
batches
push so pretty much the same code i did
in cluster
and there was light so i'm gonna start
this guy up so
so i made like any good library there's
a command line interface
so we have basically our master and we
have our slave
so our master will start up he'll sit
there waiting for people to connect
and we can start up slaves so go for his
master
so he's just gonna sit there prompt for
millions i'll start up locally
slave okay so i've
like because i have four cores on this
machine there are four so i have
um now i have eight because i have some
of my other uh guys from mid-hands for
joining so we can next if any of you
actually happen to install fourism my ip
is what do we have here
uh 192 168 159
128. so we should have more people
joining oh oh
oh wow there we go that's distributed
computing right now so that was
super cool so now where where is zul the
gatekeeper
okay i just do all the gatekeepers so
just for i've never had
32 cores on this this is like so what
the heck let's do 20 million
so let's do this so cross your fingers
so this is going off you'll see like
like your processors are going to get
little batches of jobs
like so the force is with them
they'll kind of go off we're we're kind
of turning along here
i built massive stats otherwise no one
is just waiting oh there we go
so
so that that's pretty cool that took 16
seconds and i just did 20
million of those so well i well
i'm astonished at that i'm just gonna
let's do like so another cool thing with
zero mq so you notice that
my master service um i just killed this
i'm not starting a server it's just a
this is basically a node command line
and so i killed that entire process and
all these slaves out here in the
audience
were like uh where'd he go um
but i i stopped it now i just started up
again and they've all reconnected
and you'll notice that in in my code
i didn't really do that all i did was
it's called connect so we just connected
like on port 1337
replying on 1338 and that's all we did
it's just a tcp
socket hidden but all that crazy stuff
if you've ever done like any socket work
where you're like
oh god the server like disconnected and
i guess i gotta reconnect and then get
some state back
all that's been handled for us through
zmq because these sockets
are amazing so i'm gonna i'm gonna start
i don't know let's go
i don't know wanna go 100 million oh a
thousand million w
yeah i'm just gonna let that run 1000
million is that
their word for that billion
so really that's about it because dan uh
it was a four minutes earlier i have
four minutes left
um so really as this chunks way like the
cool thing about this if you uh
if you are doing any kind of distributed
work think of as you're designing your
applications rather than thinking of
request response start trying to think
about if there's ways you can just kind
of send a message we're
infinitely familiar with how to send
messages in javascript kind of go
send this off here's a call back when
you're done um but think about
send this off send this group of stuff
off and here's a call back when i'm done
and think of the power
if you can have an unlimited number of
people out there waiting to
basically do your bidding
wow that was a minute to do a billion
that's cool that was awesome dude
actually
to add to that um 0mq is also
not linux specific right so
if you've got a whole bunch of work that
you need to get done and some of it is
to happen on windows box or you know on
a
mac machine because i don't know let's
say when we get into analyzing
objective-c and whatnot um you could
totally do that it's it's just a message
and those slaves that run on those
systems will pick it up just like
anything else if they know what to do
with it
let's go process it and respond back so
you can kind of still keep your
management and your kind of overall
orchestration and node
and just getting javascript so that
that's about it
uh thank you all so we are launching our
developer preview this is our pitch part
so if you are
interested in helping us build one of
the tools that are going to sit there
and help you guys build the best
software possible
help us help you register for our
developer preview at bit hound dot o
slash preview
and may the fours be with you thank you
you